and in Michigan another gubernatorial
race and another Rising GOP star now
once down as much as 18 points
Republican Tudor Dixon has closed the
Gap to just two points in the latest
poll Tudor Dixon joins me now tutor
what's happening here now we've had you
on a bunch of times
um and the polls have you know not been
with you for all those appearances but
now a change what's happening
yes thank you for having me tonight
Laura well it's very interesting in the
state of Michigan parents are rising up
and saying they want education back they
want their students to have a chance
they want to go back to the basics in
education Reading Writing and math and
they're fighting back against this woke
agenda in our schools and so far that's
really changing the race but also today
we were just talking to the Detroit
economic forum and we're hearing from
businesses that are saying we just need
to have support from government instead
of having government attack us job
creators want to expand in the state of
Michigan they're hearing Gretchen
Whitmer say she she has helped them she
hasn't helped them we've lost more small
businesses than any other state we also
lost 82 000 jobs they hear what she's
saying they know she's gaslighting them
and they're ready to change Turn the
page on this horrible dark time in
Michigan's history and see Michigan
Thrive again now Tudor here's what
Whitmer thinks will I guess help stop
State's declining population I don't
know what
we also need to lure people to make
their lives here in Michigan we need
immigration reform on the federal level
we enshrine Reproductive Rights into law
here in Michigan I want to go into
Indiana and Ohio and start stealing
headquarters and cultivating talent and
bring them to Michigan where you can
have full rights to make your own
decisions about your health and your
body
uh Tudor is making Michigan an abortion
Sanctuary State at the top of the
voter's concerns
absolutely not what kind of economic
development plan is that when you have a
bunch of businesses in the audience
right there saying what are you going to
do to help us that's what she's offering
is abortion it for economic development
I know what the businesses need they
want to have reduced regulation they
want a state government that comes
around them as a partner they want to
make sure we have a solid infrastructure
something that she promised in 2018 and
today when she said that exact comment
she laughed about the roads in Michigan
and said I know I know everybody's
concerned about the roads yes because
that was your number one promise in 2018
and you haven't delivered on that in
fact none of the promises that she made
in 2018 she's delivered on this is the
kind of silly rhetoric we're hearing
from her on economic development we have
a real chance to take this race back we
are two points apart we need folks to go
to tutor dixon.com and support because
we are going to get Michigan back and
we're going to thrive we'll be the
leaders in the midwest again you should
have great education yeah the thing that
I would you know say to the people out
there watching from Michigan is
is it war is this really the best you
can be I mean why why are you losing all
this population to States like Georgia
and Florida and Tennessee why I mean is
that is that acceptable to the people of
Michigan it can't be we know what the
crime rate's doing it's none of this can
be acceptable so I I think it's an easy
calculation tutor I have a very good
feeling about where this race is going
uh no more lockdowns in Michigan uh
Tudor Dixon uh we'll be watching thank
you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else